alors qu'hier le conseil scientifique
invité les français à s'auto confiné une
semaine avant noël pour éviter de
contaminer leurs proches
nombreux sont ceux qui attendent une
solution plus efficace et définitive se
faire vacciner un soin qui est loin
d'être impossible car depuis l'annnonce
de la découverte du vaccin par la
société pfizer il ya quelques semaines
les choses se sont accélérées à tel
point que le vaccin pourrait être
disponible dans quelques jours avant la
fête de noël
un rassemblement qui est au coeur des
préoccupations de nombreux français
l'allemagne a l'intention de commencer
les vaccinations le plus tôt possible et
ferait activement pression sur l'europe
pour que le médicament soit autoriser
immédiatement un projet que confirme
officiellement le ministre allemand de
la santé
l'objectif est d'obtenir une
autorisation avant noël mais si ces
autorisations étaient accordées
quand pourront être vaccinés et est-ce
que cela mettra fin à ces périodes de
confinement et couvre feux successifs
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement est avec nous ce soir on
tenté de répondre à toutes nos questions
et surtout les français vont-ils être
vaccinés avant noël
merci et gabriela talent porte parole du
gouvernement d'être avec noah 20h29 en
direct sur ces 8 et vous avez posé
énormément de questions au porte parole
du gouvernement envoyée à on est dans
l'actualité puisque jean castex le
premier ministre annonce est ce qu après
midi beaucoup beaucoup de mesure et on
va revenir sur plein de choses
est ce que bercy gabriel déjà d'être là
mais ravis d'être là mais merci ben
voilà donc c'est vous venez très souvent
sur le plateau en ce moment vous
n'arrêtez pas un virgin radio ce matin
avec bourde quand on fait bourdin le
matin on a une petite race sera ou pas
du tout petit peu le soir déjà la veille
au soir à la veille au soir je peux vous
dire quand vous faites bourde al madad
vous dormez pas de bouc interroge aussi
le charme à tous les bouquins savoie
tous les passeports va mieux parce qu'à
l'époque demandé à free de géométrie non
exploités comme ça on est pas bien
moribonde et on nous ça m'énerve c'est
que c'est pas trop table en bois
d'ailleurs ce matin on voit juste
extrait gabriel après et est d'ailleurs
passé nous dire pourquoi vous avez donné
les chiffres du premier confinement à
m'avoir gardé et mme bourden il se prend
vraiment pour un prof a pété un câble le
gars il est persuadé qu'il est au lycée
henri iv il envoie des gares au tableau
et celles ministre regarde bien voyez là
t'as le bonjour aux gens
les tests salivaires c'est pour quand
c'est un sujet qui est en contre
travailler des semaines et des semaines
j'entends parler de ces tests salivaires
qui n'arrive toujours pas couvre-feu
amateur depuis hier soir
le montant de l'amendé 135 euros s'il ya
récidive si elle récidive je crois que
c'est 1500 euros que c'est ça non non
alignement 200 euros ce sens les quinze
jours et après dans les 15 jours et
après après je crois qu'on arrive à 1500
noms dites-moi 3700 3710 mois de prison
folle pour éviter gabriela tabou repas
serait dommage c'était pas loin
franchement ça fait le montant de la
majoration de l'amant exactement
confinement et j'ai switché entre les
deux j'ai fait l'année -2
mon année vous avez raté les
encouragements prochain trimestre il ya
plein de questions est-ce que vous avez
des questions à poser à gabriel en tout
cas merci d'être là et de venir en
direct c'est extrêmement courageux
delphine la première question moi je
suis un peu anti vaccins et les choses
très naturelle et j'ai retenu qu'il ya
quelques semaines emmanuel macron a dit
que le vaccin ne serait pas obligatoire
et maintenant au final il va être
obligatoire plus ou moins ah non non non
non oui m le jour où vous voulez prendre
l'avion faudra plus ou moins de vacciner
ou faire des choses soient plus ou moins
être vaccinés au bout d'un moment la
liberté va quand même se restreindre en
main pour le real il n'est pas là du
tout et je n'ai plus aucune entreprise
ou qu'une compagnie aérienne n'a annoncé
sa wii c'est pourquoi annoncer ça allait
il ya un vaccin il ya des vaccins qui
sont en train d'être expertisées
scientifiquement il ya un premier qui
arrive là qui devrait être validé par
l'union européenne la semaine prochaine
et qui va pouvoir arriver va commencer à
vacciner mais tout ça va se faire très
progressivement et notre génération je
me mets dans la même je pense oui ça
sera un peu plus tard quand elle me
chambrer par par la vaccine va pas poser
des questions il ya nicolas pernikoff
alors moi j'avais une question vous avez
nommé un monsieur vaccin qui est
monsieur fisher et les premiers mots
qu'il a dit c'est qu'il était
extrêmement méfiant et prudent sur les
vaccins c'était il ya pas très longtemps
ouais mais je pense que c'est ça ça va
être paradoxal ce que je vais dire mais
je pense que ça doit être de nature à
rassurer quand est ce qu'il a dit ça il
a dit ça il ya une dizaine de jours que
ça à un moment où sur les vaccins qui
vont arriver
on ne disposait comme information que
des communiqués de presse des
laboratoires qui ont préparé ces vaccins
donc il a eu raison de dire moi tant que
j'ai pas vu les données scientifiques et
les études qui ont été faites par des
scientifiques indépendants
je suis méfiant et je ne lance pas des
grandes phrases pour dire il faut se
déclinent et c'est là maintenant on
commence à avoir des données assez
solide il ya deux agences sanitaires qui
ont validé le vaccin international l
agence européenne qui est en train de
finaliser ces travaux il était ce matin
sur une radio est d'ores et déjà il est
beaucoup plus confiants ils viendraient
douce alors de quel pays alors là c'est
le vaccin fader biotech qui
et qui était un consortium américain
allemand et produit en belgique et qui
va commencer à arriver on va en recevoir
un peu plus d'un million de doses en
france alors il a annoncé 1,16 million
de doses j'encaisse alors ouais ça vous
êtes merci pas avoir fait votre bourdin
est pas avoir demandé à interroger
gabriela taxe que vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous moi je me ferai vacciner
dès que le vaccin sera recommandée pour
ma génération
en tout cas dès qu'il sera ouvert à ma
génération vous avez quel âge et brianna
talent j'ai 31 ans est vraiment à des
comptes portant à 31 ans a tenté un an
j'étais en quatrième
[Rires]
aujourd'hui selon les sondages et
environ un français sur deux qui a peur
de se vacciner ou qui ne veut pas cermak
signer à l'étranger il parle de faire
vacciner des hommes politiques
importants des présidents de la
république joe biden barack obama on
parle d'une vaccination en direct des
manuels maquereau à la télévision est ce
que vous trouve que c'est une bonne idée
est ce que vous quand vous voudrez vous
faire vacciner vous seriez prêt à le
faire enfin alors juste on fera une
spéciale vaccination en direct ici
europa non mais où est ce que vous allez
le faire
non mais on s'est posé la question entre
collègues du gouvernement je vais pas
vous mentir on a eu la discussion s'est
dit est ce qu'il faudrait que tout le
gouvernement aille se faire vacciner
avant tout le monde pour donner
l'exemple et la ja roselyne bachelot qui
est mise de la culture qui était
ministre de la santé quand il avait bu
vous souvenez le virus h1n1
à l'époque il y avait une campagne de
vaccination est déjà il y avait une
défiance et elle avait fait le choix de
se faire vacciner en premier devant les
caméras c'est nous a dit ça va pas
changer grand chose parce que les
complotistes avait dit qu'elle s'était
fait vacciner avec sérum physiologique
bien sûr et savait pas particulièrement
fait évoluer les choses et voyez c'est
bien de prendre des gens d'expérience de
gouvernance au lu ment et les directions
se faisait vacciner en premier c'est que
y'a des gens qui nous disent vous êtes
gentil mais vous n'êtes pas du tout dans
les plans prioritaires il ya des
personnes qui sont hyper en risque
vis-à-vis de la maladie pourrait
beaucoup de suisses en mourir que vous
et en gros vous allez vous faire
vacciner alors qu'on aura qu'un mineur
s'était rendu le 16 millions de doses ça
va être d'abord pour les personnes qui
n'ont plus besoin on commence par les
personnes âgées dans les maisons de
retraite parce que ça elles sont âgées
parce que warhead sont en maison de
retraite est conséquent le virus rentrer
dans une maison de retraite
malheureusement il circule très bien sûr
madame en chine où on vaccine plutôt des
gens qui vont travailler qui font
marcher l'économie
en fait c'est c'est pas nous qui avons
pris la décision le gouvernement
considère que ce n'est pas une décision
politique de dire qu'ils doivent faire
vacciner en premier on a confié sa à une
agence de santé indépendante
scientifique la haute autorité de santé
ils sont indépendants on leur a dit
voilà les vaccins qui vont arriver
qu'est ce que vous nous conseillez de
faire pour lutter au mieux contre
l'épidémie et ils ont dit il faut
d'abord commencer par les personnes qui
ont le plus de risques de faire une
forme grave et de mourir pour les
protéger
benjamin castaldi vous continuez à nous
imposer est-ce que je peux le faire
vacciner même si je pas prioritaire aux
gens à leur âge et pas le droit non non
même si on évolue on a on a fait un
planning de vaccination à partir des 12
qu'on va recevoir et donc on fait par
publics prioritaires comme je le disais
à l'instant en commençant par ceux qui
ont le plus de risques d'avoir une forme
grave ou de décéder donc on commence par
les personnes âgées en maison de
retraite
ensuite les personnes âgées qui sont pas
en maison de retraite et on va descendre
progressivement les tranches d'âge
d'accord amiable justement puis la
personne âgée vous pose une question
c'est pas ça ce qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
lorsque le vaccin est sur le marché
le virus a muté puisque le virus mute
énormément eh ben c'est un risque qu'on
surveille beaucoup ah oui ça c'est les
scientifiques qui regarde ça de ce que
disent les scientifiques et notamment le
président du conseil scientifique qui
est un peu notre interlocuteur parce que
les beaucoup de scientifiques qui disent
parfois des choses différentes donc on a
un interlocuteur qui est monsieur
delfraissy qui a une carrière et une
expertise énorme mais ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'il ya déjà eu un peu des variantes du
virus mais que pour l'instant il n'a pas
muté au sens où sa protéine n'a pas
changé ça le pour l'un des vaccins qui
sont en train d'être finalisées ou sont
efficaces maintenant c'est quelque chose
qu'on surveille de dix paires près parce
que ça peut être effectivement un risque
pour le l'efficacité du vaccin si ça
devait arriver
wen question salut doute chez nous tu
nous appelles deux ennemis d'allah de
mars une question de kenji le chanteur
lenny kenji pourquoi ces vaccins tout le
monde a peur comme ça de vaccins en fait
alors qu'est ce que c'est là une sortie
ou je ne sais pas en fait pourquoi tout
le monde craint autant ce vaccin alors
que ses sens et j'irai trois choses 1
il ya dans notre pays depuis déjà
quelques plusieurs années un défiance
vis-à-vis du vaccin une crainte
vis-à-vis des vaccins en général voient
beaucoup de gens qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner et c2c un nouveau vaccin
qui arrive vite c'est vrai et donc
certains disent comme il arrive très
très vite
est ce que vraiment
secure est ce qu'on a tous regardé et 3
il ya des personnes qui sont totalement
irresponsables qui racontent n'importe
quoi sur le vaccin
c'est ça moi j'en vois sur les réseaux
sociaux je vois des personnalités des
anciens amants un moment on a dit que la
première qui avait été vacciné qui est
âgée d'ailleurs a eu des effets
secondaires c'était une c'était une
connerie sow bien ces échéances qui a
été dit par les autorités britanniques
c'est que des personnes qui avaient été
vaccinés et qui sont très allergique
série tient vraiment à des allergies
graves personnes qui prennent des angles
des ampoules d'adrénaline
quasiment tous les jours à cause de ça
avait des effets secondaires on a eu
deux et justement la fisu personnes
marginales et phares du royaume uni
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
cafouillages qui a eu parce qu'ils n'ont
cessé de revoir leur copie
la veille justement de l'administration
des vaccins ça devait d'abord est
diffusée dans les maisons de retraite
puis finalement ça a été transférée bain
de bretagne mais on en parle là
justement nos e-mails ou comme on va
prendre existait pas trop tôt mais c'est
une question mfm ça nous on a fait une
chambre prend exemple nous on a fait une
stratégie justement 13 en anticipation
et donc on commence par les maisons de
retraite et après pour les autres
personnes au lieu de faire des grands
centres de vaccination va dire aux gens
alesi ça sera par les médecins traitants
ce qui va d'ailleurs permettre de créer
de la confiance aussi je pense que les
gens ils font confiance à leur médecin
pense que si l'on la discussion avec lui
qu'il leur dit vous pouvez le faire et
c'est ça va alors les chéris poser des
questions oui mais n'essayez pas de
montrer à gabriel état de vous êtes
intelligents ils sont fous totalement
vous rentrerez pas au gouvernement
d'imposer des questions que les
téléspectateurs se pose voilà les
chiffres il n'hésite pas intelligent en
effet kelly on va passer à kelis est
mieux là alors j'ai entendu parler d'un
vaccin alors je sais pas si ça concerne
l'autre un vaccin qui allait faire
dépenser des milliards aux pays qui
veulent instaurer parce que pour la
conservation
c'était des trucs spéciaux des frigos
spéciaux il faut le faux faut faire le
vaccin au bout de 30 secondes à la
sortie est-ce que ce vaccin là qu'on a
aussi qui va nous faire dépenser des
milliards alors c'est pas du tout des
milliards ouais c'est effectivement le
vaccin fighter blendtec et y en a un ou
deux autres qui sont les mêmes dans la
même situation il faut les conserver et
les transporter à moins 80 degrés donc
c'est l'état qui arrange donc c'est sûr
que c'est pas le petit frigo qu'on a
l'habitude de voir à la pharmacie et
donc on a acheté c'est vrai des supers
congélateur ça s'appelle c'est pas du
tout des milliards avec quelques
millions d'euros alors c'est l'argent
mais si ça permet de soigner des
personnes et d'éviter qu'un an après
alors sa retraite après on a acheté les
frigos ils sont répartis